bonsoir ados alexis poulain merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france est
ce que vous êtes surpris par cette
affaire alain griset non c'est une
affaire de plus et là selon maman elle
s'allonge la liste des ministres ou des
proches de cette majorité ou du
président qui sont mis en examen qui
sont devant la justice pour des affaires
de non-conformité de non déclaration de
patrimoine
on se rappelle bien entendu à la sphère
de monsieur delvoie qui était en charge
de la réforme des retraites qui avait
lui aussi oublié de déclarer de nombreux
postes qu'ils avaient et l'argent qu'il
gagnait avec ces postes de conflit
d'intérêt permanent c'est un peu la
marque de fabrique de ce gouvernement un
ministre de la justice l'a aussi mis en
examen un ministre de l'intérieur
soupçonné de viol avec des procédures en
cours et combien d'autres conseillers
proches du président alexis colère
secrétaire général de l'elysée mais
aussi richard ferrand au perchoir de
l'assemblée nationale
bref je vais pas pouvoir faire toutes
les listes parce qu'il y en a beaucoup
mais il ya quelque chose évidemment qui
commence a cloché sérieusement avec à
chaque fois la même petite musique ou le
président renouvelle cyr confiance à ses
ministres mis en examen c'est le cas
pour le ministre de la justice eric
dupond moretti
alors sera-t-il de même avec monsieur
grise et qui va se retrouver devant la
justice l'a alors que lui travaille à
bercy ça fait encore plus c'est encore
plus dérangeant que ce ministre de la
justice donc le nouveau monde prouve
promis par emmanuel macron est une
caricature de l'ancien monde en réalité
où les affaires continuent de plus belle
avec des élus qui font un mal fou
finalement à la fonction élective mais
aussi à la démocratie représentative
il ne faut pas s'étonner après qu'il y
ait un tel désamour des urnes de la part
des français quand ils voient que ceux
qui doivent montrer l'exemple
eh bien ce sont les derniers à le faire
justement l'impact sur le quinquennat
macron de toutes ces affaires mais
d'abord ce précisément sur les
déclarations de patrimoine
ça semble quand même compliqué parce
qu'elle est grisé mais n'est pas le seul
concerné il ya aussi l'ex homme fort de
la polynésie gaston flosse l'ancien
patron de la martinique alfred
marie-jeanne le député maire bernard
brochand qui seront également jugés en
septembre
pourquoi c'est si compliqué de cette
gestion justement les déclarations de
patrimoine mais parce que c'est assez
récent finalement c'est sous le
quinquennat de françois hollande qu'on a
cette haute autorité à la transparence
de la vie publique qui demande aux élus
de déclarer tous les avoirs ils ont tous
les toutous les les entreprises qui le
président
bref d'être transparent quant à leurs
sources de revenus
et on comprend pourquoi parce qu'il ya
eu la sphère cayzac qui est passée par
là où un ministre de l'économie du
budget mantei droit dans les yeux aux
français et aux présidents de la
république en assurant qu'il n'avait pas
de compte en suisse donc il ya une
volonté d'éviter un ce précédent au
tragique et de faire en sorte que les
politiques et bien avant d'en prendre
leurs fonctions déclare de manière
exhaustive toutes les intérêts légaux
tout à fait de manière transparente
qu'ils ont dans des affaires et des
entreprises pour éviter les conflits
d'intérêts le problème c'est que comme
c'est assez récent et bien vous avez des
hommes politiques qui le font pas
vraiment sérieusement qu'ils ne savent
pas non plus remplir toutes les cases
qui oublie de bonne foi comme eric
dupond moretti qui oublient de déclarer
300000 euros roselyne bachelot qui avait
aussi oublié de déclarer les revenus qui
prônait de son cabinet de conseil bref
ça fait beaucoup comme vous dites il ya
également pas seulement bien sûr au sein
de 2,2 l'impliquant marche mais tous les
partis sont concernés rachida dati
ancienne garde des sceaux également qui
est maintenant sous le viseur de la
justice aussi pour plusieurs milliers
d'euros centaines de milliers d'euros
qu'elle aurait gagné en étant député
européen avec le groupe renault nissan
église et un ministre un prochainement
devant les tribunaux et vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure il ya d'autres ministres
si qui sont visés menacé plus tôt par la
justice vous avez cité eric
dupond-moretti aussi gérald darmanin qui
est visé par une enquête pour viol est
ce que tout ça ça peut avoir un impact
finalement sur le quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron vous le disiez mai
emmanuel macron il peut redorer l'image
de certains membres de son gouvernement
à lapproche évidemment d'une échéance
importante la présidentielle alors non
puisque ce qu'il fait emmanuel macron
c'est que vous me faites le en même
temps classique un d'un côté il promet
un nouveau monde politique avec
davantage de vertus avec justement cette
fin du conflit d'intérêts et puis de
l'autre il renouvelle sa confiance
systématiquement lorsqu'un ministre est
mis en examen et sous le feu de la
justice alors certains politiques ont
préféré se mettre en retrait c'était le
cas de françois bayrou qui était lui
aussi ministre de la justice et qui avec
la sphère des emplois fictifs du modem
au parlement européen a décidé de se
retirer mais il est revenu par la petite
porte maintenant puisqu'il est haut
commissaire au plan et qu'il compte bien
sûr dans les plans des malades mâcon
pour sa rélection 2022 puisque c'est un
allié essentiel
donc on voit bien que pour les modèles
macron les affaires sont les affaires
s'annoncent ne l'empêchent pas de
renouveler sa confiance à ses membres du
gouvernement il y as l'impression
finalement qu'il ya une justice à
plusieurs vitesses et que ça ne touche
pas les promesses qui ont été faites par
le candidat macron qui était celle
justement d'un nouveau monde politique
libéré de ses pratiques libérer de ses
habitudes
merci à vous alexis poulain
éditorialistes ans